there's a little dirt in the morels
hey
we're in the mountains
what'd you expect
this one
would be the most amazing wild mushroom
omelet
first olive oil in
get that piping hot
in with the morels
wow
bunch of salt
it can be one of the best
omelettes
anywhere delicious
a little spice with those mushrooms
it's almost like the sort of equivalent
of a
indian gaya masala which is all
different depending on what reason you
are in the atlas mountains
beautiful
really important to take the water out
of those mushrooms otherwise the eggs
are going to go really watery
and the nice thing now is to get some
color on those mushrooms
come on
after foraging for these mushrooms
repelling down a waterfall
trust me
you know i'm a big lover of scrambled
eggs
and
omelets so perfect omelette
eggs in
don't season it
until you start cooking it
eggs in
let's make it a generous omelette shall
we
now
from there
lightly fork
the eggs
before those mushrooms come out
they'll touch a butter in there
all the water's gone you can see the
color on the mushrooms now
i've kept the heat in the pan so we've
got that nice
saute flavor as opposed to boiling
mushrooms look at those
so good
so good
now
once those mushrooms
have reduced in size got the color on
there
okay
flatten them out
that's what we have to be quick now okay
season into the eggs
a little touch of ras alanut
mix
and then she goes
straight on now
work that okay
work it
cook the eggs that's what happens when
you work it
so you're working the pan
you take it to a stage where it's almost
just a little bit liquid
in the center
don't worry about keep on mixing that
over
the idea is to get all those eggs nicely
cooked
and even distribution of those mushrooms
and look
flatten it all out nicely
okay
i'll lightly season that
in the center
and then from there
some beautiful
ghost cheese
now
sprinkle that on that's going to be that
nice salty flavor
to the omelette
not
let that start to melt
take
the chill
that just lifts the bottom of the
almonds
from the pan
spatula
[Music]
i want you to literally let the pan do
the work
how we do the
let the pan do the work tilt the pan and
literally just fold it over now
get in
cheese is just the under melt
tilt the pan as it goes down let it roll
round
and finally
that
is a beautiful
omelet
boom
there we go
the most amazing omelet
served with incredible porcini
morales
chanterelle
probably the most expensive omelet
tonight in the atlas mountains
wow
delicious
even though there's a little dirt in the
morels
hey
we're in the mountains
what'd you expect
let me eat this please
let me know in the comments what you
think of that amazing scrambled egg dish
and if you missed uncharted trust me you
can watch it on the link below or on the
nat geo app